نشره الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
اصيب شابا فلسطينيا خلال اقتحام قوه
الاحتيال الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم بلدتي
قباطيه والزبابده جنوب محافظه جنين بالضفه
الغربيه هذا واعتقلت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي احد عشر فلسطينيا في انحاء
متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه
وافاد نادي الاسير الفلسطيني بان حملات
الاعتقالات تركزت في كل من قرى وبلده
نابلس وجنين ورام الله وطولكرم وقد تم نقل
المعتقلين الى مراكز التوقيف للتحقيق معهم
في قضايا تتعلق بمقاومه الاحتلال
الوقوف على المشهد ينضم الينا من رام الله
مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري اهلا بك
وليد نتابع معك اخر المستجدات
نعم 11 فلسطينيه اعتقالتهم سلطات الاحتلال
الليله الماضيه وفجر هذا اليوم تركزت بشكل
خاص في شمالي الضفه الغربيه وتحديدا في
مدينه نابلس حيث يقتحمتها قوات الاحتلال
واعتقلت شابين لكن الابرز كان في بلده
قباطه وبلده الزبابده جنوب شرق مدينه
الجنين هناك وقعت ايضا الاشتباكات واصيب
بمغاطيتين بجراح هذا الوضع الليلي في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث تقوم قوات
الاحتلال بشده حملات الاعتقال حسب نادي
الاسير الفلسطيني فان العام الماضي عام 22
شهد سبعه الاف عمليه اعتقال ويبدو ان هذه
السياسه ماضيه بها قوات الاحتلال هذا
الشهر هذا هذا العام ايضا الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده وهي عباره عن توليفه
من اقصى اليمين المتطرف وهناك اجنحه
العنصريه فيها
تحاول ان تثبت انها لا تقله همم عدوانيه
للفلسطينيين عن سابقاتها ففي خلال ليلتين
قتلت فلسطيني اول ليلتين من عمر هذه
الحكومه
قتلت فلسطينيين في وهدمت منزلين وايضا كان
هناك الاقتحام للوزير بين الاقصى بالاضافه
الى انها قصفت مطار دمشق ومناطقه هناك
بمعنى انها ماضيه بسياساتها سواء على
الصعيد تعاملها مع الفلسطينيين او على
الصعيد الاقليمي همم ايضا وواضح بان قادم
من الايام قد تاتي بتصعيد اضافي نظرا لما
يصدر من تصريحاته عن المسؤولين في هذه
الحكومه واستعداداتهم لسن قوانين تعيد
انشاء المستوطنات التي كانت قد اخلاها ال
شارون عام 2005 في ايطاليا خطته للانفصال
عن غزه وكان قد اخذ اربعه مستوطنات شماليه
الضفه الغربيه وهم الان يسرعون من
اجراءاتهم في محاوله لاعاده الاستيطان
فيما عرف بمستعمره حومش المقامه على اراضي
قريتي برقه وسيله الظهر بين الجنين ونابلس
هذه المؤشرات جميعها بان هذه الحكومه تدفع
نحو الانفجار وليس نحو التصعيد فقط
فالتصعيد حاصل على ارض الواقع وحملات
الاعتقال المتواصله في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
الى جانب عمليات الهدم للمنازل والمتوقع
ان تزداد خلال الايام المقبله ايضا وقتل
الفلسطينيين هي سياسه تواصلها هذه الحكومه
والتي وصلت ذروتها كسياسه تصعيديه في
اقتحام بني كثير الاقصى صباح امس والذي
تبين انه كان منسقا حتى دق التفاصيل مع
رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه تتشكل
من حيث بقى اللكود لكن الابرز القوه
الاساسيه فيها هي الصهيونيه الدينيه وهي
حزب
عنصري عندما فاز في الانتخابات وقبل ذلك
رفع اتبعه شعار الموت للعرب وهذا مؤشر اخر
على ان عمليه قتل الفلسطينيه بنظرها هؤلاء
هي تبدو وكانها امرا اعتياديا وقد يواصلون
اعتداءاتهم من خلال ثلاث من اشياء تخدمهم
وهي لها واجب علوم بالاضافه الى ما يعرف
او همم فتيه التلال هؤلاء يسنونها الهجمات
واعضاء الكنيست والوزراء يغطون عليهم
ولديهم ايضا جمعيه ومؤسسه تديرهم وتقودهم
ايديولوجيا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
الاضاحات